son muy buenas noches a ambos así bien
pues en esta copa tan atípica como verán
aquí en la plaza de rocío que es una de
las plazas principales de lisboa es
donde se llevó a cabo donde están
celebrando los pocos hinchas del bayern
múnich que vinieron hasta lisboa hasta
la capital de portugal es en esta plaza
donde se instaló esta orejona gigante
que ustedes ven a mis espaldas y bueno
la verdad es que no hay cientos de
alemanes en la capital no hemos visto
tantos hinchas de los bávaros como si
los hay desde la parís han rama que
igual estuvieron muy contentos igual
festejaron y por ahí de vez en cuando
pasan y se dicen cosas entre hinchas
pero todo está digamos en un ambiente
muy tranquilo efectivamente sí pues eso
es una desdicha para los parisinos para
los hinchas parisinos que estaban muy
impactantes pues con lágrimas en los
ojos
ustedes saben pues es un partido que se
jugó a puerta cerrada en el que no hubo
público en ese bellísimo estadio de la
luz que puede tener un aforo de 65.000
personas y sin embargo pues los cientos
de hinchas
a parisinos que vinieron precisamente
hasta lisboa para esa final pues la
mayoría vieron el partido en bares y
restaurantes en todo el centro de la
capital donde había varios lugares
porque era la única forma de poder
hacerlo pero pues ellos de todos nos han
explicado a lo largo de estas semanas
desde que el parís ángel man llegó aquí
a jugar esos cuartos de final contra el
atalanta de bérgamo pues que ellos
venían aquí a apoyar como diera lugar a
su equipo
natalia y como viste el partido cuál es
tu análisis de esta gran final que se
esperaba pues fuera muy reñida que se
iba a ganar en las áreas bayern munich y
logró pues con el dominio de las áreas
tanto de la propia como de la contraria
al definir la ocasión que tuvo de gol
crees que fue un justo resultado crees
que hubo sorpresa déjame decirte aquí
que louis con voz de profeta le atino al
campeón de la europa league eso cuando
se lo pregunten semifinal y si también
latino aquí al campeón de la champions
league cuál es tu impresión de la final
natalidad fue justo el resultado
pues bueno psoe luis yo también le iba
por lo mismo que decía luis para mí el
ganador de esta copa iba a ser el bayern
munich creo que había un poquito un poco
esa historia de tener por primera vez un
equipo que ganara todos los partidos
consecutivos 10 11 partidos con esta
final en esta liga de campeones- aquí
vienen los del bayern que siguen muy
contentos festejando este sexto título y
si efectivamente pues creo que fue un
partidazo eso de eso creo que no hay
duda y eso es algo muy bueno porque
hubiera podido ser un partido de pronto
muy difícil para los parisinos y que
quizás hubiera podido de alguna manera
cerrarse para el parís saint germain
desde muy temprano y sin embargo no
fácil yo creo que el país en llamas
salió con muy buenas intenciones con muy
buenas ganas y que además tuvieron ya un
momento puede ser complicado desde el
octavo minuto pero pues para una ocasión
que tuvo neymar y sin embargo la
desperdició es de hecho en ese primer
tiempo pues esa delantera estrella esa
delantera estelar del país en rama tuvo
tres ocasiones y no pudo no pudo
concretar ninguna
ellos así que creo que de todas maneras
el parís ansia man salió muy bien y por
el otro hablado pues creo que también
que flick tuvo muchas razones de haber
puesto a coman y no a perisic que se
habían habían dicho que era como la
sorpresa de la alineación de hoy y
finalmente pues fue esa sorpresa la que
marcó el gol y la que dio el título así
que yo creo que es una victoria más que
merecida para el bayern que viene
haciendo una campaña extraordinaria un
equipo que no ha perdido ningún partido
en el 2020 y sobre todo flick pues que
llegó con esa ambición y sobre todo con
una visión muy objetiva de lo que él
quería en un momento incluso yo yo aquí
me decía que eso era algo que les
gustaba mucho justo en el momento en que
flick pues se convirtió en el director
técnico del bayern múnich a finales del
año pasado